[Music]
if you're a trump supporter I'd like to
talk to you for a little while about
dogs and cats dogs and cats and horses
and hamsters and guinea pigs and snakes
and any other animal you love because
with one change made under this
administration a lot of them are going
to die and a lot of them are going to
suffer and you and I won't even be able
to find out that it's happening I am
proud to tell you that I date the actual
beginning of my life - when I got my
first dog not even five years ago I grew
up in an allergic household and then I
was always at work and though I always
loved dogs it just wasn't possible and
then it happened anyway and if you have
a dog or two or 37 or a cat or a dozen
cats or if you have ever loved an animal
you know you could have been one of the
people I called up in the months after I
was born again to whom I said why didn't
you tell me that dogs are one of the
meanings of life like I have to tell you
this here's what has happened that has
put the cousins of your dog or your cat
where your bird at risk you may have
heard that the new administration has
altered information and is even
considered wiping out data at the public
websites of all sorts of different
federal agencies well one of those
agencies is the US Department of
Agriculture and last Friday the
department of agriculture the USDA
suddenly and without any warning removed
the inspection reports and other
materials about the mistreatment of dogs
and cats and other animals and dog and
cat breeders at zoos at research
laboratories in circuses even included
in this the USDA took down the records
of breeders and zoos and labs and other
places that have violated the Animal
Welfare Act and the horse Protection Act
that puppy breeder you want to know
about do they create the mothers and
make them breed until they die do they
make the dogs or cats live in filth do
they give a damn about them the animal
research lab at a university or
government facility or just at a place
where they hurt the animals for money do
they do anything to keep the lives of
these
wonderful creatures from consisting only
of misery and pain and torture you will
now have to fill out government
paperwork just to find out if it's
happening you will literally now have to
file a Freedom of Information Act
request just to find out and that often
takes years in seven different states
you can only buy a dog at a pet shop if
the dog breeder has a good inspection
report from the Department of
Agriculture but now those reports are
gone why well no records means we don't
know when the rules have been violated
or by whom or the details of any
inspections or if dogs and cats and
other animals are living in pain and in
fear and if we don't know how the laws
are being enforced the people running
puppy mills and medical experiment labs
well they have less incentive to obey
the laws they did this cover it up for
the humans who abused dogs and cats they
just did this for money you know what
this is this is shameful if you like
Donald Trump you and I disagree about
how he is treating people and which
people and we can discuss that some
other time this is about dogs and cats
and horses and Trump and the bottom line
is last September we asked the Trump
campaign if he had ever had a dog or a
cat they had said at the time they had
no evidence that he ever had one of the
co-authors of one of his books told me
he never remembered hearing Trump so
much as mentioned having a pet as a kid
or as an adult until one has loved an
animal said a man named Anatole France a
part of one's soul remains unawakened
Google this yourself there's there's
nothing no evidence Trump has ever loved
an animal there are 78 million dogs in
this country right now 86 million cats
that does not include the ones in those
puppy mills or experimental labs or
those who are homeless
and now in the Trump era we not only
can't try to help them we can't even
find out what has happened to them when
did I mention the other thing the part
about the new risk not to some lab dog
or a puppy mill mother the part about
the new risk to your dog during the
campaign the Trump people briefly put
out a proposal to limit what it called
the FDA food police in part because the
FDA quote even dictates the nutritional
content of dog food well it does do that
the FDA Food Police insists that dog
food cannot be sold if it has poison in
it 23 times in one year the FDA food
police reportedly recalled pet food 11
of those times it did so to pull
poisoned pet food off the shelves but
that costs money and it hurts the pet
food companies profits and the pet food
companies profits are now more important
than whether or not your dog lives or
dies until one has loved an animal a
part of one's soul remains unawakened
can you look at your dog or your cat
right now and still support this man
thanks for listening
hug your pet for me